hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought this big piece of land and
our prototyping a more sustainable way
of living not sure how it's going to go
but let's see
and this video is number 38 and every
eighth video we talk about our current
problems or challenges as we like to
call them
so in this video first we're going to do
that i'm going to talk about the
problems we currently have
then i'm going to share you an offer for
someone to come here and help out and
receive 10 000 euro which is kind of
exciting
and finally i'm going to sit down with
rita to do a q a so we're going to
answer questions you guys posted in the
previous video
a lot to do so get started
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so let me first recap on our
previous challenges
first one was flies there were just a
lot of flies flying around around and
they're in your ear your head
[ __ ] flies do you like them oh yeah i
love them so much can you hear how much
i love them it's just very annoying it
continued to be like that for a while
now it's actually getting less and
according to the neighbors it's actually
these two periods in the year you have
them a lot in the spring and in the
autumn so hopefully we're good now for a
while
and the second challenge we had was
video making that it's kind of hard to
integrate this into our workflow here
and that problem actually became a bit
bigger so let me explain
so with video making we mean making
these weekly update videos for you guys
where we document the things we learned
or did put it in the video and then you
guys can watch it and it's actually a
really nice process because it allows us
to share the things we learn or the
mistakes we made
it's a fun way for ourselves to keep
track of all the things we do it's a bit
like a diary and it also generates
income from the revenue from youtube
which has been super nice actually so
you watching these videos helps the
projects a lot so it's a very
good thing for the project to have these
videos
so the problem is we won't be able to
keep it up like this because few reasons
first is
one week is short to do and something
meaningful and film and edit that in the
same week it's intense second now we're
just with two people here so it's kind
of easy to have an overview of all the
things that going on but the more people
come and the more chaotic it's gonna be
and the more complex to manage it all
and plan everything and third i'm
currently the one making the videos and
editing them and it just takes a lot of
my time
and in the end the goal of the project
is to find a way how to live sustainable
and video making is sort of a secondary
thing so i'd rather focus my time on the
long term goal and the mission of the
project instead of making videos
and doing both at the same time is just
going to slow down our progress so i'd
rather focus on the long term mission so
yeah in a way video making like this is
unsustainable because we're not able to
keep it up
but we did come up with a plan on how to
move forward with this
let me show you so in order to
understand our plan forward you kind of
need to know a little bit where we're at
so a brief recap
about one year ago we came to this land
here the first update video of project
camp on the land and the land had
nothing so we decided to set up a base
camp with basic infrastructure so we
have some water electricity shelter
basically a place where we can stay
and besides setting up the base camp
also understanding a bit where we are
what are resources available around here
how are the neighbors
what's the land even like what's the
difference in autumn and spring
and it's been great we learned a lot and
now it's time to move forward to the
next phase and we needed to find a
little bit of a structure on how to
continue this development is it always
ongoing is it inversions like fresh
plastic
so we decided to work in seasons
[Music]
so what this means is basically we work
from march april
until november and then we do a lot of
work and then we take time in winter to
reflect and take a break and plan the
next phase the next season
so now season one is almost finished we
have a few more things to do to set up
this base camp it's
making a few roofs that protect us for
the rain in the winter but then
it should all be good so the plan is
then also to really stop making videos
to say we take a break we reflect and we
plan what's coming next
and season two would then start again in
april
and the nice thing is that it's actually
a bit aligned with the real seasons so
in spring summer you have more energy
you do a lot of things and autumn you
start to wrap up and in winter you take
time to reflect and read charts
so it seems like a pretty good long-term
way to develop this project and this is
actually kind of scary to stop making
these videos because
well first youtube really likes
reoccurring videos so make them every
week or every day even
because that's what the algorithm likes
so the moment you do that it spreads it
around more
so not doing that or breaking that
pattern it's kind of risky and the
second one is you guys might actually
just forget maybe now it's in your
pattern
um but if we quit for a few months we're
not sure if you guys are still there
so this would actually be a good moment
to go to that subscribe button like down
below and add the little bell to it so
you get a notification when a new video
comes up
so we have a few more videos now to
finish up season 1 but the next season
season 2 would start the 14th of april
so make sure to mark that in your
calendar somewhere because if we all
watch that video we're back into this
algorithm thing
so you might wonder where is season two
about what's gonna happen to be honest i
don't know yet because we're going to
plan that this winter but what we do
know
is that making video is going to be an
essential thing for it okay so we need a
video maker which could be you or your
friend but we basically need one person
to be here to make the videos for season
two which means you need to be here from
march until
november to capture all the things and
produce one video each week and upload
it to youtube and that will be your main
task to take care of that in exchange we
can give you a place to sleep we cover
your food expenses so you don't have any
cost on that and we can give you 10 000
euro for the whole period of time you
can find more information on the website
support.project
but we do need to be convinced that you
can do the task
by sharing some older videos you made or
a portfolio because it is quite a
complex thing to do to upload the video
each week but also be in this setting
where it's kind of rough
not super stable it's not like we have a
super nice office here where you can
edit your video
so it's quite an adventure and a
challenge
i hope we find someone it would also be
good for you guys on youtube because it
would increase the quality
so make sure to spread it around to your
friends or video makers that you know
and maybe i'll see one of you guys here
for season two
[Music]
all right it's time for a q a to answer
uh some questions you guys have
scared
i guess
[Music]
why are you not posting regular videos
or at least three or four videos in a
week
we really love to watch your videos so
we want to get a bit more frequent yeah
g think a pani i would say come here and
make the videos question from vivofocto
how often do you use the pizza oven
not often enough but maybe in the coming
future it will be easier as
there is something coming up to
protect the pizza oven so you can have
pizza for breakfast
and for lunch
a question from diana marie are you
intending on having merchandise
might i suggest you offering chunks of
rope and roof tiles people buy anything
that's a good suggestion
i would be curious who would take the
broken roof tiles from the land
let us know your address and we'll ship
you one
central portugal seems to be a bit of a
hot spot of similar echo homesteading
projects on youtube
what about getting together with
collaboration and skill swap yeah it
sounds like a cool plan uh up until now
actually we didn't really do much
in general we didn't really go out of
the land much and if we did we met with
the neighbors or some local people
so yeah maybe we'll do that in the
future and once we have a bit more time
on our hands question from lars ericsson
in the last video everyone was there
where did tl go who stays on the land
regularly and what's the cadence of
visits from your team
what is candy i don't know
yes last video there was
a few people or the late videos there
was the few people on the land most of
the people we knew already and people
that came to help out with specific
tasks actually that you saw also on the
videos at the moment is just the two of
us back to us and
adrian and julian
julie stefan g
do you still want to update the project
camp academy website regularly
certainly i would say that's also the
backbone of this whole project
i think we did notice that we need a bit
of more time to really make sure the
knowledge we gather is accurate and
complete enough
so we'll probably take a bit longer
before it really ends up in the academy
but 100 sure that is coming uh do you
have an actual roadmap with milestones
you would like to achieve in the
forthcoming one to two years
at the moment not really like i
mentioned before in the video we're
gonna take the winter to make this road
map and planning so 14th of april you
would know
you have fresh water from the well where
does the waste water go
yeah the waste water so far doesn't have
a very perfect system everything goes
back to the land but as we also use
everything bio-degradable
it's not a big problem so far
to be improved
michael when are you getting your
electricity tools review
not sure still on the list to do but i
feel like i just want to use them a lot
before i make a review
but if you guys want to see it let me
know then i can put some urgency to it
with the amount of different ground
levels in the land are you considering
building a pumped hydroelectric storage
facility as a big battery
not
yet not yet question from gabrielle sung
tell us more about your relationship
between you even if it's just the basics
we are in a relationship
that's the basic
we work together
malikoi
do you have any profit generating
operations on your property
funny actually a lot of neighbors always
ask this how do you make money from your
land whether to put on eucalyptus or to
grow crops i would say we don't really
know we also not really intended to make
money from the land i think we're going
to find some sort of weird business
model between making money from youtube
patreon donations people volunteering
but it's still still very abstract at
this moment
any plans on building a rainwater
catchment storage structure on the land
uh so far not very specific plants for
sure it will be highly needed in the
coming future and that will be also a
basic part of the ecological design
question from jordan do you plan to get
livestock soon like goats and sheeps
no not for now for now what we have is
just
neighbors shepherds that bring their
goats and their ship to our land
eating bushes yeah
if you if you were to start over again
is there anything different you would
have done things like location layout of
the land or natural resources
hard to say really because i think you
learn from all the things you do looking
back i prefer to have a land without
highway sounds i would say
some things we thought would be more
important for instance when we were
looking for land we were looking for a
land close to the grid so we could hook
up electricity for running machines
now we kind of skipped that step and
went straight to solar which is pretty
doable
so that could have been actually easier
when we looked for land if it didn't
need to be close to the grid
but overall i would say um good lesson
learned so wouldn't really redo it
question from vivofoto what's up with
the noise of the highway
yeah still there
still there still there
federico neto do you guys plan on
keeping the precious plastic mission
uh project cam seems so far from urban
plastic seems weird
to import plastic into the countryside
yeah i agree it's kind of weird to see
plastic in this setting
however we did find a few applications
where it would be super nice to actually
have recycled plastic for instance in
tubes
for the drainage from the water they're
now always new pvc
you could use recycled plastic for that
we're going to do a try out with the
roof dial from recycled plastic
so we tried to find a few applications
where it could be useful but in general
i would say they're pretty separated
indeed it's more of an urban city
setting they're recycling and here it's
more of a
natural organic setting
have you already chosen a wood chipper
like your friends suggested no not yet
we really want to get one
the thing is that there are a few things
to decide and you can decide to hook a
wood chipper on a tractor and for that
we also need to decide that we want to
have a tractor or you can decide to have
a more
a wood chipper with its own um engine
uh
lots of questions around the wood
chipper still let us know if you have
any suggestions
it's always inspiring to see the ease
you have to meet new people in places
how do you reach them
how is it to film everything people you
just met
yeah it's gita she
is good with people
it's not just
jonas lima what you guys are planning
about receiving people in the future i
mean i love the project and would love
to help out or swing by when i'm in
portugal uh no we are not open for
visits yet
if you want to help out in the future
next season you can see
support.projectcamp.com
and in there we have specific tasks
where you can check and see if you have
the skills and the joy to sign up
question from maxwell gold is rita your
secret weapon when it comes to
befriending all these fantastic local
people
yes we should ask that question yes
have you thought about filming
exploration videos of going around the
nearby villages to source building
materials or waste materials that can be
used or
re-proposed by project camp yeah i
thought about it looks super cool as
well many settings but we need people
helping with video
but yeah many more interesting places to
film
question from jonathan loman how will
you be staying warm in the winter
lots of blankets
and
some fireplace and i don't know some
cardio exercises hot chocolate
hot chocolate could you give us some
global updates about how you plan on
interlinking the three projects precious
plastic fixing fashion and project camp
i'd say at the moment they're quite
developing individually
one army is the umbrella foundation that
binds them together but i think it's in
the small details that we can have
overlapped that we use some precious
plastic for instance here or people in
the press classic use fixing fashion
so i think in general it's a lot about
developing the individual projects and
the later stage they really gonna join
more each other's forces hi
are you going to do a video on where you
got your solar equipment and what it
costs you we already have two videos on
how we built the electronics and how we
set up the panels
uh i think in general in the academy we
would have a more toro section where we
really explained about solar
but that would be more later on from
harry kut
how and when will he define success if
you don't really have a specific goal
how do you find working and motivation
for a non-exact quest
question uh
i don't really know to be honest
i think it would more get more clear
over time as we develop and as our goal
becomes a bit more clear
for now i would say it's just a lot of
intuition and joy that keeps us going
forward
and i guess at some point it would be
become a bit more
of a clear mission
yeah and the success probably also comes
with motivation and vice versa
you plan to get some goats or sheep to
mow your huge meadows no not right now
goats are very wild
it's our most requested
youtube comment
that we should cut codes
what is needed to join your project
i would say it depends everyone can join
but you need to have a task that fits
you so if you go to
support.projectcamp.com you can see
which task fits you and if you have the
skills for it and then you could come
that said i would say season one is
closing so not many open tasks it would
more start again in season two so keep
an eye on it
what are your plans for winter are you
going to drive the van under a roof
somewhere or make some kind of furnace
to get warm yeah as they've said before
there will be a point that we will take
a break and we will drive a bit off the
land
but
otherwise we will also be around and
just take it a bit
with the winter mode so slower and just
drink lots of hot chocolate no chocolate
hot chocolate question from scott butler
would love to support you via patreon do
you belong
we belong
we belong we vlog
what are you
joe t what are your thoughts on veganism
and are many of you vegan yourselves
talking about living sustainable and
responsible lifestyle project camp this
will be an easy place to begin
good
luck yeah i would say it's a
rather complex question to
answer
uh
dave and i are vegetarian we get tons of
eggs from our dear neighbors
so i would say definitely not vegan so
far
but yeah it's not very linear
when we were here with big groups we
decided to go fully vegan on the kitchen
but
that's how far as i can go with the
answer
yeah sometimes it's just it's hard to
see what is more sustainable to get
weird exotic
food from the other side of the world
that is vegan or get more close by
things that are non-vegan
i think we don't have the answer yet so
still
exploring so if you have suggestions let
us know
jeremy and tunis
can you please use another music for
your videos yes jeremy i've seen your
comment before
i actually already changed music from
free music on youtube to signing up for
soundstripe
i guess i'm just not good at selecting
the right music so if you have a library
or something
bring it
so this was it for this video i hope now
you have some of your questions answered
probably new questions popped up now
next video you will see
this structure a bit more
finished we hope
next year we can have a helping force
very joyfully making the videos and
helping out
they really need the support in there
right
thanks for watching see you in the next
video